jessica is with us in Toledo Ohio hi
Jessica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Thank
You mr. Hamby hey what's up so my
husband and I are in baby step 3 I'm we
are at October of 2018 my husband since
I didn't happen pregnant and we have a
two-year-old my husband announced
recently that he wants to divorce and he
left the day before Christmas and I just
want to know what to do financially I do
not want to go back into debt
I want to provide the best I can for my
daughter and our upcoming child and I
want to be showing them the best way to
live that out as well oh my goodness
bizarre circumstances why in the world
happened our pastor and all of our
evangelical Christians people are
wondering that but an affair is part of
it oh okay because his timing is amazing
a pregnant wife and on Christmas Day he
moves out I mean that's that's pretty
smelly yeah yeah well I'm sure you're
simultaneously angry and hurt and I'm
sorry wow what an incredible thing
you're facing
are you working outside the home do you
have a career yes I have a full-time
career and I made about 42,000 gross
reasonable about 50 to 55 okay all right
have you seen an attorney yes and what
is the attorney I know you well I don't
agree with the matter so I don't want to
file for the worst so I'm waiting on him
to make sense that's himself okay I
don't have a problem with that
I want you to be protected because
basically you know a guy who leaves a
pregnant wife and a baby leaves himself
in a position to be owned by you and
that attorney needs to be willing to do
that because he's but that's how these
you know child support to the max and
then whatever else we want to get and
the the if there's I know you don't want
this divorce but it may not be up to you
yeah and III hope for and pray for
reconciliation with you but right now
you've got a very very very bizarre
situation and it doesn't look real good
with the numbers you with the facts you
gave me anyway I'm sure there's more to
the story but that we're not going to
cover on the radio but the if this thing
does tip and does go the way it appears
to be going to a divorce a friend of
mine that does divorce recovery as a
divorce recovery ministry says that
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction and that's the switch that
will have to flip at some point inside
your mind and certainly already has
flipped with your attorney if you're if
you have a good attorney meaning how
much financial support are we going to
get out of this guy for you to start
your new life and that certainly is a
minimum of child support but there's a
lot of other stuff I'm going after if
it's this guy this guy's really stepped
in it you want to piss a judge off leave
a pregnant wife on Christmas Day I mean
that's just really pissed as a judge off
because because judges are human you
know and so that he's not in a very good
negotiating position like has none
ability whatsoever so anything that's
his may be yours is what I'm saying and
that's okay I'm fine with that
to take everything he's got so that
these kids have a future because he's
walking off and including his income so
you got to get in a position to do that
and to the extent that that does or
doesn't come then you start running your
life on forty two thousand plus or minus
whatever other support you get right
and so how much debt do you guys have
did you say you just got debt-free and
started your emergency fund right yeah
so I can thank him for helping me pay
off my student loans
yeah well that's that's the least he was
going to do but any retirement any
retirement plan he has or anything else
is probably coming to you you have very
small retirements and some plans right
now you need to get a again you need to
get all there is to get because you're
going to need it
so the how much is your house payment
750 a month okay
and you know you can probably make it on
that if you want to but you're going to
be maybe looking for other sources of
income and it's going to take a while
for you to really start getting
financial traction again but the first
goal is to tread water and make it on
42,000 and keep the house payment
current until we get this settled and we
know what we're getting from him but
he's paying all this child support he's
paying it on time he's paying anything
else that he's supposed to pay according
to the settlement that comes out and or
you're gonna have to be very diligent
not as an act of vengeance although
that's tempting but as an act of mother
hen protecting her chicks you're gonna
need the money that the court says he's
supposed to give you and but I think you
can probably budget with no debt and
make a 750 house payment on your income
it's going to be tight but I think you
can do it don't you I didn't hear that
eternity leave okay and so it's unpaid
for six weeks the following six weeks
your phone is ruffled so you need to
speak directly and I have 60 percent pay
for six weeks and no pay for the flash
six weeks and you're five months
pregnant five and a half five and a half
okay all right so third trimester barely
I'm are coming up on it anyway yeah okay
so what we need to do is pile up as much
money as we can pile up and and then see
if you may be in a position you don't
take the entire maternity leave okay you
may go back to work early no law says
you have to yes I had to with my last
one too so time and but I don't want you
to but I don't want you to be in this
whole situation and you don't want to be
in this whole situation
so if you're physically able you know
one option is to get back early so that
you don't drain out this emergency fund
that you just built and and the other
thing is how much of an how much can we
add to that emergency fund just really
piling up cash aggressively between now
and the time baby comes and again you've
probably already done a lot of this
stuff but any extra work you can do and
I don't know how you're gonna do that
five and a half months but anything you
can do to create extra income selling
stuff is there something we can sell is
there something we can liquidate of his
that the attorney says is okay and just
turn a big [ __ ] a big war chest to
get ready to fight number one but number
two but number one get ready to cover
the maternity leave time off but all
baby steps are on hold right now no
retirement savings know investing of any
kind and you're squeezing every dollar
out of your budget anything you can do
any money you can get from him during
this time like if he's going to help you
pay the house pay or anything like that
any money that you can squeeze out we're
going to out of your budget you're going
to throw into a pile here to get ready
for the maternity leave and that'll
hopefully give you the ability to take
the whole maternity leave or at least a
portion of it so I'm so sorry you're
facing this it sounds like you got a
pastor in a church around you to walk
with you through this and that's a good
thing you're gonna need some people on
you while you're doing this in your life
while you're doing this and it's a tough
thing you're walking through I'm so
sorry what a disaster
you